En este video hablaremos de excitación de
electrones. Podemos interpretar esto de dos
formas: que los electrones pueden ser emocionantes
y que los podemos excitar a niveles de energía más
altos. Y vamos a pensar en lo que sucede cuando
dejan de estar excitados, cuando regresan a
niveles de energía más bajos. Y para ayudarnos
a comprender esto, voy a comenzar con un átomo
simple. El hidrógeno es el más simple que conozco,
y vamos a pensar en la versión del hidrógeno más
común: el isótopo, que sólo tiene 1 protón en su
núcleo y que normalmente tendrá 1 electrón. Si es
un átomo de hidrógeno neutro, normalmente estará
en su estado fundamental si aún no es excitado,
por lo que estará en la primera etapa. Pero
puede excitarse para llegar a otras capas,
podría excitarse para llegar a la segunda capa,
a la tercera capa, o a la cuarta capa. Y este
dibujo que estoy haciendo no es exacto, lo hago
sólo para ayudarnos a visualizar esto. Sabemos
que los electrones no orbitan los núcleos como lo
hacen los planetas con las estrellas, en lugar de
eso tienen propiedades tanto de partículas como
de ondas, y tienen una función de densidad de
probabilidad, en donde podrían encontrarse. Estos
niveles de energía están asociados con diferentes
densidades de probabilidad de varias energías,
pero digamos que es así como se ve típicamente
un electrón si nos referimos a un sólo átomo de
hidrógeno neutro, en donde el electrón está en su
estado fundamental. Ahora digamos que tenemos un
átomo de hidrógeno en donde el electrón ya ha sido
excitado, en lugar de estar en la primera capa
se encuentra ya en la segunda capa, justo aquí,
y lo que vamos a hacer es golpearlo con un fotón
para excitarlo aún más. Sabemos que la luz tiene
propiedades tanto de onda como de partícula, y
cuando pensamos en la luz como una partícula nos
referimos a ella como fotón, que voy a representar
así. Esta luz tiene una longitud de onda de 486
nanómetros, y sabemos que ese fotón golpea al
electrón con una energía de 486 nanómetros,
tiene suficiente energía como para excitarlo más,
y en este caso que pase de la segunda capa n2 a
la cuarta capa, por lo que va a llegar hasta
acá, entonces absorberá a ese fotón. Y luego,
después de un tiempo, puede volver a bajar. Puedo
hacerlo aquí. Entonces después de un tiempo ese
electrón de aquí, ese electrón excitado, puede
bajar de la cuarta capa a la segunda capa,
y al hacerlo va a emitir un fotón de esa misma
longitud de onda, va a emitir un fotón de 486
nanómetros. Con esto comenzamos a comprender que
los fotones que tienen la energía correcta pueden
excitar a un electrón y subirlo a una capa o más
de una capa. Cuando hablamos de mecánica cuántica
tenemos la noción de que los fotones necesitan
una cierta cantidad de energía para poder excitar
al electrón al siguiente nivel de energía o al
nivel de energía posterior, las cosas intermedias
no funcionan y lo mismo es cierto cuando los
electrones emiten energía, los electrones no van
a pasar del cuarto nivel de energía a algún lugar
entre el cuarto y el tercero, no pueden hacer eso,
tienen estos estados cuánticos y sólo pueden
estar en la cuarta o en la tercera o en la
segunda o la primera capa no hay nada parecido a
una capa tres y medio. Y con base en esto podemos
pensar en cuál es la diferencia de energía
entre estas capas. La diferencia de energía
entre las capas es esencialmente la energía del
fotón que se emite cuando el electrón pasa de la
cuarta capa a la segunda capa. Para averiguar la
energía de ese fotón, sólo tenemos que pensar en
algunas fórmulas útiles en la mecánica cuántica.
La primera que podemos ver aquí es que la energía
es igual a la Constante de Planck multiplicada por
la frecuencia. Esta cosa que parece una v es en
realidad la letra griega minúscula nu [ν], y esto
es lo que usamos normalmente para la frecuencia,
especialmente cuando hablamos de frecuencias de
cosas como la luz. Y también sabemos cómo pasar
de frecuencia a longitud de onda, porque vemos que
la velocidad de la luz es igual a la longitud de
onda de esa luz multiplicada por la frecuencia
de esa luz. Entonces, ¿cómo calcularemos la
energía de un fotón de luz de 486 nanómetros?
Bueno, podríamos pensarlo de esta manera:
primero podemos calcular su frecuencia usando c,
que es igual a lambda por nu [c = λv]. Permíteme
escribirlo. Entonces sabemos que la velocidad de
la luz es igual a la longitud de onda de la luz
multiplicada por la frecuencia de esa luz. Y si
conocemos la longitud de onda, podemos calcular
la frecuencia dividiendo a ambos lados entre λ.
Vamos a hacerlo: si dividimos ambos lados entre
λ tenemos que la frecuencia de la luz será igual a
la velocidad de la luz dividida entre la longitud
de onda de la luz. Recuerda: nos han dado la
longitud de onda de la luz aquí, 486 nanómetros,
luego puedes tomar esto y usarlo en la ecuación
de Plank, aquí arriba, en la que la energía es
igual a la constante de Planck multiplicada por la
frecuencia. Permíteme escribir esto: la energía es
igual a la constante de Planck multiplicada por
la frecuencia [E = hv], y tenemos la frecuencia
justo aquí, entonces será igual a la constante de
Planck multiplicada por la velocidad de la luz,
dividido entre la longitud de onda de la luz, que
sabemos es de 486 nanómetros. Entonces podemos
decir que la energía es igual a la constante de
Planck, multiplicada por la velocidad de la luz,
dividida entre, en lugar de escribir la longitud
de onda como 486 nanómetros puedo escribirla como
4.86 x 10¯⁹ metros. Un nanómetro es sólo una mil
millonésima parte de un metro. Y luego podremos
sacar nuestra calculadora: sabemos cuál es la
constante de Planck, nos la dan justo aquí;
sabemos cuál es la velocidad de la luz, aquí
también, y sabemos que tenemos un máximo. Aquí
nos están dando cuatro cifras significativas en
cada uno de estos, y por aquí hay tres cifras
significativas, entonces nuestra respuesta debe
tener tres cifras significativas. Voy a escribir
la constante de Planck: 6.626 x 10¯³⁴ Js, y lo
voy a multiplicar por la velocidad de la luz,
por 2.998 x10⁸ ms, lo que es igual a esto.
Y luego voy a dividir esto entre 486 x 10¯⁹,
lo que me da. Pausa dramática. Me da esto, y como
queremos tres cifras significativas, esto sería
4.09 x 10¯¹⁹. Aquí nos dan la constante de Planck
en Jules, así que esto es igual a 4.09 x 10¯¹⁹ J.
Esto nos dice que la diferencia en estos niveles
de energía es esta cantidad de Jules, o la energía
de ese fotón que tiene una longitud de onda de
486 nanómetros, esa energía es 4.09 x 10¯¹⁹ J.